let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 and see what's on people's minds
starting with our caller from the 4 0 1
area code who's calling today from 4 0 1
hey David my name is Kenny how you doing
good Kenny how's it going I'm doing well
first-time caller longtime listener
recently picked up a membership thank
you you've been doing such a great
coverage of the primaries Frisian I
wanted to call so I'm actually out here
you'd be Berkeley on a graduate student
and I'm sure you've heard about the
strike that's going on in Santa Cruz yes
I wanted to get your take on it because
I'm a pretty active member with the
Union here on campus and as you know the
wildcat strike that uh isn't endorsed by
the Union officially and for political
reasons I won't be putting in my two
cents but I want to get your tape Thanks
you know I just don't really know enough
about the circumstances to be able to
comment I know that when I was an
undergrad at the University of
Massachusetts there would very often be
a varieties of different types of either
protests or strikes from the graduate
student organizations or different
groups and I just feel like it would be
inappropriate for me to really weigh in
because I don't I'm aware of it I don't
know all the circumstances and I I just
don't think if there is any any benefit
to me giving an uninformed opinion about
something so specific so then can I ask
you a more general question sure um
given what we did what we've seen
recently with big labor pushing back on
things like Medicare parole and
attacking the Sanders agenda because of
some of the quote-unquote things that
they fought for so far on what rules do
you think big labor has to play in
something like this do you think that
worker strikes can be effective without
big labor and where do you think that
the or what do you think the University
of California
I guess that's specific so let's just
stop there as far as Big Labor goes so I
believe that it is completely incorrect
to suggest that Medicare for all as an
example is something that Big Labor as
you call it should
opposed because it takes out of the sort
of negotiating package or what's under
the umbrella of Big Labor to do for
their union members in fact I saw an
analysis that was that was different
which is if you take something like
healthcare out of the negotiation for
Big Labor because you have a
medicare-for-all program Big Labor now
can specifically know in the number of
dollars per employee that were
previously being spent on health
insurance and can argue that there
should be raises at least for some part
of what that savings is so I reject
completely the idea that on principle
Big Labor should be opposed to something
like Medicare for all and I don't
believe all Big Labor is I mean we heard
from some Union unions that actively
excuse me activated around that issue
but it has not been all of them and I
don't buy that for a second I think that
that's a talking point meant to stifle
support of progressive candidates and
it's a talking point meant to support
it's a staple support of Medicare for
all interesting yeah David dole had a
similar not completely the same take but
uh
in a similar vein so thanks um last
thing where can I find the show being
live-streamed right now it's on the
members we don't we don't stream the
show life the show is produced in the
afternoon and then released a few hours
later so only only like the evening live
streams are actually available available
live Kenny thank you so much for the
call I appreciate hearing from you as
many of you know I am super careful
about where we publish and distribute
David Pakman show content it's a really
important decision that we make where do
we want our content to be we don't want
to spread ourselves too thin but we want
to make sure that we're taking advantage
of good platforms where our content
could do well and over the last couple
of months I've been testing publishing
our content to a platform called library
that's lbr why I've mentioned it once or
twice before and we are absolutely
loving it it's a fantastic platform
where our revenue as publishers does not
depend on some algorithm deciding
whether an ad should run before a video
or not in fact it's actually an ad free
platform where our revenue is the
and by the number of people that watch
our videos and also by the tips that are
left for us in credits that are in
platform credits it's their own sort of
currency so to speak by viewers like you
and right now for people who sign up on
this platform it's completely free using
the link down in the video description
for every verified sign up we get a
little bit of a credit and you also get
a credit of tips that you can then leave
on content that you like such as the
david pakman show content that we are
publishing so use the link down in the
video description
no algorithmic determinations about
whether we get to make money or we don't
get to make money or any of that stuff
all of our video content is being
published there use that link sign up
you'll get a credit will get a credit
and it's a beautiful thing and I'll
update you guys in a couple of weeks
about how it's going there's also a
contest that they're running
whoever can refer the most new users
gets a huge reward which would be a big
big boost to us so check it out link
down in the video description sign up
let me know what you think